dans l'actualité ce soir la chine tente
de secourir les victimes du tremblement
de terre dernier bilan 20 à 30000 morts
ou disparus sous les décombres la pluie
battante complique les opérations le
régime se dit prête à accepter l'aide
internationale mais pose ses conditions
encore un rebondissement à l'assemblée
pour la loi ogm le texte a été rejeté
faute de mobilisation des députés ump
toute la procédure est à refaire la
gauche et les anti ogm exulte que s'est
il passé
invité ce soir jean françois copé
président du groupe ump à l'assemblée
bonsoir et à tout à l'heure je pense que
ce n'est pas foutu petite phrase de
nicolas sarkozy qui veut convaincre que
la france peut renouer avec la
croissance et le pouvoir d'achat
le chef de l'état défend des dans
l'isère la loi qui instaure notamment
plus de concurrence dans la grande
distribution pour ou contre le service
minimum d'accueil à l'école
le gouvernement va l'expérimenter pour
la deuxième fois l'occasion de la
journée d'action des fonctionnaires
après demain les syndicats d'enseignants
dénoncent une remise en cause du droit
de grève
michel fourniret a tenu son engagement à
la reprise de son procès le tueur en
série présumé sorti de son silence
il adresse des excuses non pas aux
familles des victimes
mais au juge d'instruction enfin c'est
l'autre anniversaire de ce mois de mai
il ya cinquante ans le général de gaulle
revenait au pouvoir pour fonder la vème
république
au delà du chef politique quel homme
était de gaulle c'est le dossier de
cette émission
bonsoir et bienvenue à tous et bien une
course contre la montre qui est engagée
en chine il est bien difficile ce soir
d'établir un bilan avec précision mais
trente six heures après le tremblement
de terre des milliers peut-être des
dizaines de milliers de personnes sont
ensevelies sous les décombres et
recherché par les sauveteurs jérôme
berlin
pour lui c'est déjà trop tard à chaque
minute qui passe l'espoir de retrouver
des survivants s'amenuise mais parfois
au fin fond d'un amas de béton une voix
répond tout va bien tout va bien on va
venir vous chercher
depuis trente six heures c'est une
course contre le temps
dans cette région où certaines villes
ont été rasés à 80% il faut faire vite
très vite
extraire les survivants on parle encore
de milliers parfois de dizaines de
milliers de personnes prises au piège
même le pouvoir chinois reconnaît un
désastre majeur plus grave que ce qu'il
avait imaginé sont coincés là dessus
depuis hier et ils sont peut-être déjà
mort en personne n'est venu les secourir
non personne trente six heures déjà
depuis ça
ils se poussent de plus de deux minutes
filmée ici dans l'aéroport de chengdu et
qui a plongé dans la terreur toute une
région balayée rayé de la carte des
écoles des usines comme celle ci
effondrée alors que les 6000 ouvriers
venaient de reprendre le travail
un millier d'entre eux manquent à
l'appel certains hôpitaux n'ont pas plus
résister cette infirmière appelle
désespérément une collègue prise au
piège
plus loin les survivants ont monté un
hôpital de fortune sous des tentes
on peut aller chercher personne
on n'est pas assez nombreux il n'y a
plus que des bénévoles ici quant aux
hôpitaux rester debout
ils sont pris d'assaut un flot
ininterrompu de blessés pour leur venir
en aide
cinquante quatre mille soldats ont bien
été mobilisés mais l'état des routes
dévastées les glissements terrain les
éboulements freine l'acheminement des
secours et la pluie incessante
aujourd'hui le brouillard empêche les
hélicoptères de l'armée d'intervenir
impossible donc de parachute soldats et
vivre sur les zones les plus reculées
parfois pourtant certains sauvetage
acrobatiques sont possibles ici des
dizaines de personnes sont restées
coincées plus de 24 heures dans ce
téléphérique avant d'en être délivrés
face à ce nouveau défi
la chine a accepté l'aide internationale
et sur la télévision d'état
on appelle toute la nation à se mettre
au service de la région sinistrée
collecte de sang don d'argent même le
premier ministre montre l'exemple
depuis la nuit dernière cet ancien
géologue est partout un mégaphone à la
main il rassure les survivants
tenez bon dit il l'armée arrive
la chine veut montrer qu'elle maîtrise
la situation quelques points de repère
pour bien comprendre le sichuan où se
trouve l'épicentre du séisme est une
région montagneuse située entre eux le
centre le sud ouest du pays presque
aussi grande que la france est peuplé de
90 millions d'habitants la balle à terre
a tremblé au moment où les élèves
étaient en classe les secours
concentrent leurs efforts sur plusieurs
écoles ou lycées qui se sont entièrement
effondré renaud bernard un miracle après
18 heures de recherche les secours
retrouvent un écolier vivant il est
coincé sous un bloc de béton dans son
école ils étaient 900 quand tout s'est
écroulé à 50 km de l'épicentre du séisme
la ville de dujiangyan plusieurs écoles
ont été rasés les enfants pris au piège
en plein cours
pour tous linceul des couvertures et des
bâches en plastique au passage des
brancards qui transportent les corps
sans vie
les parents impuissants craque
mêmes scènes d'apocalypse non loin de là
dans le district de beichuan
et là encore des enfants que l'on sort
des décombres pour un raid et celle ci
qu'il nouvelle miraculé mais la montagne
s'est effondrée l'école a été écrasée
dax
ça fait boum boum de jour comme de nuit
depuis la première secousse
les secouristes recherchent des
survivants ici un père tient la main de
son fils ensevelies il s'accroche à
l'espoir qu'il va survivre comme sept
autres écoliers sauvées des ruines
il y a les victimes directes et puis il
ya les millions de rescapés de sinistrés
est là aussi l'inquiétude est vive car
ils sont très nombreux à dormir dehors
par crainte des répliques
or les nuits sont encore froide et il
pleut vous l'avez entendu sans
discontinuer philippe rochot l'ennemi
numéro 1 ce soir c'est la pluie qui
gênent le travail des militaires et des
sauveteurs chargés de dégager les
centaines de victimes encore bloqués ils
n'ont pas pu aller plus loin que cette
ville de doute yang yang alors que
l'épicentre du séisme est encore à 50 km
de là des survivants ont peur et
redoutent de nouvelles secousses
ils ne veulent pas rentrer chez eux on
ne peut pas rester dans les maisons
c'est trop dangereux il faut rester
dehors pour éditer un nouveau choc
c'est plus sûr ils sont ce soir 20
millions à dormir sous la pluie ou sous
les étoiles dans les régions sinistrées
même à chengdu la capitale du sichuan au
pied de la statue de feu le grand
timonier mao zedong comme s'il pouvait
encore les protéger
on doit rester dans ce square ce soir on
ne peut pas rentrer chez nous tente la
télé et la radio ne rompt pas annoncé
que la situation s'est améliorée mais ce
soir des milliers d'habitants de chengdu
en préféré quitter la ville pour aller
dormir à la campagne la température ne
dépasse guère 3 ou 4 degrés et l'armée
n'a pas assez de tentes pour les
protéger du froid
cinquante mille soldats sont chargés de
s'occuper des victimes et des survivants
cela ne sont plus à plaindre mais des
dizaines de milliers d'autres
d'une aide à 50 km de là dans toute la
région les aéroports sont fermés depuis
hier après un long voyage notre envoyé
spécial samah soula vient d'arriver ce
soir à chengdu la capitale régionale
elle nous a fait parvenir à à l'instant
ce premier témoignage toute la province
reste extrêmement difficile d'accès les
aéroports sont soit détruits soit fermée
nous a fallu faire de longues heures de
route pour accéder à la zone en arrivant
à chengdu la capitale du 7 juin qui
compte 10 millions d'habitants nous
avons découvert une ville fantôme les
habitants traumatisés par les répliques
ont préféré partir dans les campagnes
avoisinantes
ceux qui sont restés dorment cette nuit
sous des vaches malgré les pluies
torrentielles
une situation météo qui aggrave
considérablement les conditions de
secours les secouristes ont du mal ont
un mal fou à parvenir au plus près des
sinistrés les hélicoptères extrêmement
précieux dans ce genre de situation pour
accéder aux populations les plus
inaccessibles ne peuvent pas décoller
les parachutage de vivres ou donne sont
impossibles et ce soir ce sont encore
des dizaines de milliers de personnes
qui attendent des soins et des secours
l'autre élément qui retient l'attention
c'est l'attitude des autorités elles ont
réagi rapidement l'évoqué tiers et on a
vu tout à l'heure que le premier
ministre affiché sa compassion bonsoir
pascal golomer vous êtes en direct de
pékin la chine a par ailleurs indiqué
qu'elle acceptait l'aide internationale
mais avec des conditions finalement
assez restrictive oui c'est vrai le
gouvernement a réagi très vite dès ce
matin il a réagi favorablement aux très
nombreuses propositions d'être venus de
l'étranger mais c'est le chef des
secours qui a aussitôt précisé les
choses
oui aux chèques oui à l'argent oui
également aux vivres aux médicaments aux
produits de première nécessité au sens
on l'a dit parce que là la croix rouge
chinoise a lancé un grand appel aux dons
mais pas question en revanche
d'accueillir sur place des équipes
étrangères de sauveteurs expérimentés ou
de médecins spécialisés dans les
catastrophes comme l'avait pourtant
proposé plusieurs pays alors la chine
explique qu'actuellement les conditions
sur place sont extrêmement difficiles et
qu'il est
même impossible pour certaines de ces
équipes d'accéder aux zones sinistrées
certes la chine n'est pas la birmanie
elle a énormément de moyens de secours
l'on parle ce soir de plus de 50 mille
soldats mais tout de même on sent bien
que la volonté d'agir vite et dans la
transparence cave est affiché le
gouvernement chinois depuis hier et bien
cette volonté trouve ses limites
espérons que les sauveteurs chinois
seront seuls faire face à l'énorme défi
qui les attend dans les prochaines
heures
merci pascal golomer une dernière image
même si elle peut sembler incongrue
celle de la flamme olympique qui
poursuit son parcours en chine malgré la
catastrophe mais les réjouissances qui
entoure le relais ont été réduites en
signe de deuil et une minute de silence
sera observée avant chaque départ à
l'étranger encore la birmanie reste
sourde aux appels du monde aujourd'hui
l'onu a plaidé en vain pour un pont
aérien pour secourir les sinistrés du
cyclone
conséquence la population doit
essentiellement compter sur elle même
sur ceux qui ne sont pas les plus
touchées images ici d'une distribution
devant un temple bouddhiste le régime
des généraux estime pour sa part que les
besoins de centaines de milliers de
survivants ont déjà été satisfaits un
avis qui n'est bien sûr pas partagé par
les organisations internationales et
humanitaires
d'autant que là bas aussi la pluie
complique bien sûr l'assistance la plus
en asie et les incendies aux etats unis
cette fois c'est la floride qui est
touché des milliers d'hectares et des
dizaines de maisons sont parties en
fumée dans la partie centrale de la côte
atlantique
le gouverneur de l'état a décrété l'état
d'urgence la garde nationale sera
bientôt déployé l'activity lui alité
française dominé par un nouveau couac
sur les ogm et il est de taille puisque
la fameuse loi qui a déjà suscité tant
de débats a finalement été retoqué ce
soir au moment du vote définitif à
l'assemblée alors que les députés ump
sont bien sûr théoriquement majoritaire
que s'est il passé
explication thierry curtet marque de
langenhagen majorité absolue 136% 36
contre 135
la vice présidente de l'assemblée
nationale non
pas ses yeux sur les bonnes la gauche
c'est un tonnerre d'applaudissements
l'opposition vient de stopper l'adoption
du texte sur les ogm à une voix près
c'est une question préalable doit
députés communistes et 300
parlementaires un lieu en conséquence
mais mon projet de loi est rejeté et on
les couloirs et dans les rangs de la
majorité c'est la stupéfaction jean
françois copé le patron des députés ump
vient devant la presse
on s'est fait avoir sur un incident de
procédure j'en suis le premier désolé et
naturellement je suis pleinement mes
responsabilités
ma faim en même temps il faut bien voir
que cela n'enlève rien au fait que le
texte va continuer son chemin
pour le député communiste auteurs de ce
coup de trafalgar pour la majorité c'est
parce que ce texte n'est pas acceptable
beaucoup de députés ump n'est pas parce
qu il y avait les absents
et cette cette armée de députés l'ump
absent de la séance c'est quand même
révélateur
n'oublions pas que le vote en première
lecture il ya une majorité seulement de
20 voix au tour de l'assemblée les anti
ogm ont manifesté toute la journée le
premier ministre a d'ores et déjà
annoncé que les textes doit continuer sa
route malgré tout il réunit une
commission sénat assemblée
impensable pour noël mamère pense que ce
serait un déni démocratique que de
revenir devant l'assemblée nationale en
faisant que l'uci cet après midi ce
mardi 13 mai
rien ne s'était passé josé bové et les
manifestants ont prévu de fêter leur
victoire temporaire devant le ministère
de l'écologie ce soir jean françois copé
qui est donc avec nous alors évidemment
ça fait désordre est ce que ça signifie
jean françois copé que vous ne tenez pas
vos troupes
ça m'excite d'hommes parcours et moi
j'en assume les responsabilités je suis
président du groupe dans la vie il faut
assumer les choses donc il nous a manqué
une voix à l'occasion de cette manoeuvre
de procédure assez classique je vous
avoue quand on était nous même dans
l'opposition il nous arrive est
d'utiliser sa raisons de l'aimer
oui c'est d'ailleurs bien pour ça que
nous essayons nous mobiliser mais vous
voyez ça s'appelle un accident de
parcours je l'assumé comme je vous le
disais à l'instant je voudrais quand
même dire une chose c'est que cette loi
sur les ogm
c'est une réforme extrêmement courageuse
c'est normal qu'ils aient des débats
mais en même temps il faut bien avoir en
tête une chose elle continue nous avons
eu une lecture au sénat
une lecture à une écurie l'assemblée et
une lecture au sénat maintenant nous
sommes dans la dernière phase
il ya eu cette question préalable qui a
d'ailleurs un effet pervers c'est qu'on
avait 800 amendements déposés par la
gauche
on ne va pas pouvoir examiner mais
est-ce que ça n'est pas le reflet des
états d'âme des parlementaires ump sur
ce texte qui était assez discuté assez
controversée dont certains pensaient
qu'il était imposé par l'exécutif
franchement je crois pas je vous le dis
et je vous le dis il a de ce texte il
est équilibré et et même si à un moment
il ya eu un petit décalage et j'en
connais que ça fait polémique c'est ce
décalage a été rétablie au sénat là
c'est tout simplement vraiment un
accident de procédure alors je l'assumé
parce qu'effectivement il nous a manqué
un peu de monde dans l'hémicycle sur
cette notion là on avait largement
repoussé la précédente et d'une heure
avant c'est les charmes de la procédure
parlementaire
cela dit ça
demain nous sommes en commission mixte
paritaire assemblée sénat le texte va
suivre son corps parce que c'est une
obligation mais vous comprenez les qu'on
aime c'est une réforme courageuse
comprenez que ça vient après d'autres
couacs de la machine gouvernementale et
parlementaire de la majorité et on ne
peut pas s'empêcher de se dire c'est un
nouveau signe de malaise j'entends bien
ce message qu'est ce que voulez que je
vous dise nous sommes nous engager dans
de très nombreuses réformes
il faut tout les faire les unes après
les autres elles sont toutes difficiles
d'ailleurs personne ne voulait les faire
avant les ogm
je serai avait tout le loisir de le
faire il ne l'avait pas fait et c'est
vrai pour tous ces textes c'est normal
qu'ils aient du débat c'est normal
qu'ils de la polémique et c'est normal
que malheureusement parfois il ce petit
ce type d'incident nicolas sarkozy est
sélectionné il a continué nicolas
sarkozy dans les faux nez nous sommes
parlés absolument et j'ai assumé meuse
et dans la vie quand vous êtes patron de
vos députés qui a un couac vous
l'assumez c'est ce que j'ai fait auprès
de lui comme je le fais devant vous
c'est ma responsabilité mais pour autant
le travail de réforme continue et notre
vocation c'est d'être aussi courageux et
réformateur que présents dans le public
parce que nous les députés ump c'est
notre feuille de route et on continue
merci d'avoir accepté notre invitation
jean françois copé nicolas sarkozy on
l'évoqué qui était à vienne dans l'isère
pour défendre le projet de loi sur la
modernisation de l'économie et notamment
le volet qui vise à instaurer plus de
concurrence entre les grandes surfaces
sur place alexandre kara c'est désormais
la musique de chaque déplacement
présidentiel
applaudissements et sifflets mais les
supporters et manifestants mélanger
pour nicolas sarkozy le pouvoir d'achat
c'est encore le sujet du jour
une usine de produits laitiers un
dialogue avec les salariés
la recette qu'il affectionne mais il
faut bien chercher sur les prix sinon
qu'est-ce que je vais faire je vais
laisser les pressions
je sais par orange mettez vous à ma
place et pour agir sur les prix
nicolas sarkozy veut jouer la
concurrence d'abord en facilitant
l'implantation de petits supermarchés
jusqu'à 1000 mètres carrés
ensuite en libéralisant les négociations
sur les prix entre grandes surfaces et
fournisseurs
il n'y a pas de raison qu'on ait des
prix plus chers ici que partout ailleurs
en europe
donc d'un côté on veut libérer la
possibilité de travailler davantage pour
gagner davantage et de l'autre on veut
mettre davantage de concurrence pour
permettre d'avoir des prix qui baissent
et vous rendre du pouvoir d'achat je
vois pas comment on peut faire autrement
du rôle de séducteur à celui de
président volontaire nicolas sarkozy
joue sur toute la gamme est une fatalité
ou sk une solution est ce qu'on va
pouvoir y arriver
ou est-ce que tout est foutu mais moi je
pense que c'est pas foutu un message
aussi à destination des députés de l'ump
car sans surprise ils sont divisés sur
le sujet entre libéraux et des penseurs
du petit commerce pour nicolas sarkozy
il reste quelques jours pour convaincre
pour éviter à tout prix un nouveau couac
dans la majorité alors on l'a entendu le
texte vise notamment à encourager les
négociations entre la grande
distribution et les fournisseurs pour
faire pression sur les étiquettes on
s'interroge souvent sur le décalage
entre les prix versé au producteur et
ceux qui sont affichés dans les magasins
la flambée des cours des matières
premières a parfois bon dos
exemple les laitages enquête séverine
lebrun pascal caron une exploitation
laitière dans le nord pas de calais ici
chaque année 230 mille litres de lait
sans produit est désormais chaque goutte
compte car en un an le prix du litre a
augmenté de 25% une forte demande
internationale
la cherté du fuel et de l'alimentation
du bétail explique la flambée des
violences autour de léon sens très bien
le prix du lait a augmenté très près du
bien pour notre trésorerie parce que le
heureusement même qui augmente et parce
que les charges ont augmenté également
et
sinon on aurait vraiment du mal dû faire
face conséquence dans les rayons la
valse des étiquettes yaourts fromages
des prix en hausse de 10 à 30 % sur
certains produits
les grosses industries elle invoque la
flambée des matières premières ces
hausses de tarifs seraient légitimes
selon eux ce n'est pas l'avis de ce chef
d'entreprise lui produit des yaourts à
boire comme ceci est dans une bouteille
le lait représente à peine 10 % du prix
final est toujours des petits malins qui
en profite d'une hausse de matières
premières pour gonfler un peu leurs
marges au passage
mais si on réfléchit par exemple à une
hausse de 20 % de la matière l'est ça
n'impacte en fait le prix grand public
que de 4% mise en accusation les gros
industriels renvoie donc la balle aux
hypermarchés qui aussi augmenté leurs
marges
la grande distribution se défend tant
qu'il ne pouvait pas discuter les prix
il ne pouvait pas les faire baisser
dès que je pourrai discuter les tarifs
jeu pourrait refuser des hausses trop
élevé s'il ya deux fournisseurs 1 qui
propose une hausse de 12% et l'autre de
18 %
je pourrai dire à celui qui augmente
trop ben désolé on fera pas à faire une
chose est sûre en tout cas selon les
dernières prévisions le prix du lait
n'est pas près de baisser toujours dans
l'actualité sociale c'est après-demain
jeudi qu aura lieu une journée d'action
qu'on annonce importante contre les
suppressions de postes dans la fonction
publique et notamment à l'école selon
les principaux syndicats près de deux
enseignants sur trois devraient être en
grève dans le primaire le gouvernement
souhaite expérimenter à cette occasion
et pour la deuxième fois le service
minimum d'accueil dans les écoles
de quoi s'agit-il reportage à étampes où
il est appliqué depuis plusieurs années
édouard baer jan samia lui même après
demain
ce professeur des écoles fera grève mais
ces élèves pourront quand même venir à
l'école pour un cours de mathématiques
comme cet après midi mais pour des
activités encadrées par des agents
municipaux
à chaque grève depuis plus de dix ans la
ville d'étampés actifs son service
minimum à l'école les parents sont
prévenus une semaine à l'avant ce soir
cuerrier pourquoi un service souvent
pour accueillir les enfants à l'école à
l'école il n'y a pas de souci ici on
parle de dispositif spécial accueil des
enfants
une quarantaine d'agents communaux et
mobilisés principalement des animateurs
de centres de loisirs ou de cantine
ce jour là ils sont payés par l'état 90
euros pour 6 heures prélevés sur les
retenues de salaires des grévistes et
tous semblent y trouver leur compte mais
qu'un accueil des enfants et je sais pas
ce n'est pas forcément une mauvaise
chose
après il faudrait peut-être le
dépolitiser puis par ne pas l'utiliser
comme provocation que je crois qu'il ya
un bras de fer comme tout le monde
politique le monde syndical qui est
peut-être pas utile du côté des parents
on ne trouve rien à redire à cette
mesure
moi et mon épouse on travaille tous les
deux donc ça permet de d'avoir une
garantie de pouvoir déposer son enfant à
l'école
lors de la dernière grève la mairie a
accueilli 123 enfants sur les 2500
inscrits à la maternelle et en primaire
et le maire n'y voit aucune atteinte au
droit de grève c'est respecter les
opinions c'est respecter le droit de
grève mais c'est apporter un service
parce que c'est de la compétence je
pense que la porte est un service et une
commune doit par caceis à sa population
en janvier plus de 2000 communes
volontaires sur 22500 ont rejoints et
amp en appliquant le service minimum à
l'école et selon un sondage csa le s m a
donc service minimum d'accueil à l'école
serait approuvée par 60% des français
sondage à lire dans le parisien justice
michel fourniret a tenu son engagement à
la reprise de son procès le tueur en
série présumé est sorti de son silence
il a notamment adressé des excuses au
juge d'instruction il a aussi fait face
à deux de ses victimes
dominique verdeilhan bruno vignais
25 ans plus tard elles refont face à
michel fourniret pour les faits dont
elles ont été victimes il a été condamné
à sept ans de prison
à la barre cet après midi cette jeune
femme raconte qu'elle a échappé au pire
parce qu'elle a tenu tête à son
agresseur j'ai pris les devants j'ai
réussi à rester toujours très calme a
essayé d'être puissantes conduit pendant
près de trois heures michel fourniret
est bombardé de questions par ses
victimes d'hier vous demandez vous ce
que l'on a pu ressentir
elle est où votre sincérité alors pour
la première fois michel fourniret
s'explique pain de sa façon d'aborder
les jeunes filles je sais que c'est
grave ce que je vais dire je n'ai pas
l'impression d'agresser quelqu'un sans
réfléchir un mécanisme de cinéma se met
dans ma tête
plus tard alors qu'il évoque sa quête de
la virginité il dit je suis un homme
dangereux et je le suis toujours mangé
par l'élan créé plus de ne pas parler
parce qu'il a besoin même si dit qu'il
veut pas être le héros je ne sais quoi
j'étais dans des écrits qui la fin 84
dit qu'il imaginait il est obligé
d'imaginer des scénarios mais en fait
lors de ses précédents procès michel
fourniret avait énormément parler il
avait demandé pardon et fait une
promesse qu'on victime ne jamais
recommencer et se faire soigner on
connaît la suite
une nouvelle pétition d'usagers
mécontents des transports publics
parisiens il s'agit cette fois de la
ligne la plus fréquentée de france et
d'europe le rer a qui relie l'est et
l'ouest de la région parisienne il est
en quelque sorte victime de son succès
complètement saturé un million de
voyageurs un jour sur deux le moindre
grain de sable a donc des conséquences
énormes enquête romain messi vivien
ussel
des trains surchargés des voyageurs qui
restent à quai sur internet les vidéos
d'usagers en colère sont éloquentes aux
heures de pointe le rer a est une ligne
totalement saturé plus d'un million de
personnes l'empruntent certains jours un
record mondial
gare de vincennes des tracts et une
pétition pour exprimer un ras-le-bol
et très souvent bondés tous les jours il
ya des problèmes sur cette ligne et
mettre plus d'une heure pour aller
travailler ça normal ici les usagers de
la ligne à réclament des trains à deux
étages pour voyager moins serré beaucoup
de malaise
presque un malaise par jour et je pense
qu'effectivement c'est spécifique à
cette nuit à cause de la saturation
et en plus la chaleur parce que les
rames pain ce niveau ne sont pas qui est
vrai que ces gars du nord sur les lignes
b et d du rer
les voyageurs connaissent la même galère
tous les jours des annonces de retard ou
davari avarice et le second avarice le
déteste en fait parce qu'on savait tout
est à 21 ans c'est vrai que c'est un
problème technique c'est quelqu'un qui
est tombée sur la voie au coffre-fort à
paris la sncf et la ratp partagent la
gestion du rer et tous les problèmes qui
vont avec
sur la ligne à qu'elle exploite la ratp
promet des améliorations rapides dans
l'heure de pointe le nombre de trains va
passer de 24 à 27 le généraliser les
voitures à deux étages sur la ligne à
qui sont un bon moyen de d'emporter plus
de voyageurs
le coût est de l'ordre du milliard
d'euros à plus long terme la ratp
préconise un métro circulaire autour de
paris pour les trajets est ouest afin de
désengorger le rer
en bref on l'évoquait hier l'autopsié
d'abdelhakim ajimi mort vendredi après
une interpellation mouvementée à grasse
révèle que le jeune homme est mort à
suite à une asphyxie mais qu'il
souffrait d'une malformation cardiaque
ces résultats ne permettent donc pas de
déterminer les responsabilités une
enquête judiciaire a été ouverte pour
homicide involontaire à l'étranger une
série d'attentats à la bombe en inde à
sur des marchés de jaipur la capitale du
rajasthan dans le nord-ouest du pays il
ya soixante morts et 150 blessés
un temple hindou a notamment utilisé des
groupes d'extrémistes islamistes sont
montrés du doigt par le gouvernement
central aucune revendication pour
l'instant
aux etats unis les bureaux de vote ont
ouvert en virginie nouvelle étape des
primaires démocrates
hillary clinton par nettement favorite
mais cette victoire annoncée ne devrait
guère modifier le rapport de force avec
barack obama
résultat cette nuit là relève d'une
dynastie en italie la dynastie agnelli
qui possède notamment les voitures fiat
aujourd'hui c'est un tout jeune homme
john elkann petit fils de gianni agnelli
qui a pris les rênes du clan familial
une aventure industrielle de plus d'un
siècle
karine comazzi à rome les italiens le
surnomme ils doivent hanotaux le minot
mais aujourd'hui à 32 ans john elkann
est nommé à la tête de l'empiré agnelli
qui pèse 8 milliards d'euros
les résultats de fiat sont bons et nous
espérons qu'ils le resteront at il
sobrement déclaré
la voie était tracée dès son plus jeune
âge par son grand-père le flamboyant
gianni agnel il voyait en lui un membre
de la race des patrons de son aïeul il
n'a de commun que l'élégance le goût du
risque et l'amour de leur équipe la
juventus
john est un garçon plutôt discret qui ne
se montre aux enterrements de son grand
père et de son oncle le jeune
polytechnicien dû passer par les stages
d'ouvriers et de vendeurs un parcours du
combattant dans la grande tradition de
la saga agneaux 1899 giovanni agnelli
créé la fabrique italienne d'automobiles
de turin une usine modèle avec piste
d'essai sur le toit 1966 son petit-fils
jany playboy de 45 ans abandonne la
dolce vita pour faire du groupe un
empire automobile mais le rêve italien
s'achève dans les années 2000 fiat
connaît la crise en 2003 avant de mourir
l'avocate désigne son dauphin son petit
fils john devient vice président nous
allons dans la bonne direction at il
déclaré ce soir le jeune homme est
réputé pour conduire prudemment
c'est l'autre anniversaire de ce mois de
mai il ya 50 ans tout juste en 1958 le
général de gaulle revenait au pouvoir
pour fonder la vème république
plusieurs ouvrages reviennent sur la
personnalité est ce qu'on pourrait
appeler la face cachée du général on va
y venir dans un instant mais avant
petit rappel d'histoire pour les plus
jeunes que s'est il passé en ce mois de
mai 1958
daniel wolfromm colombey les deux
églises depuis 1946 illustres
personnages vivent est ici retiré dans
sa boisserie mais la traversée du désert
de charles de gaulle allait prendre fin
car cette crise algérienne qui durait
maintenant depuis quatre ans elle est
poussée le général entrer de nouveau
dans l'histoire
il est 19 heures le 13 mai 1958 il ya
tout juste 50 ans alger s'embrassent de
nouveau un comité de salut public menée
par des militaires et des gaullistes en
appel au général de gaulle pour résoudre
une crise politique qui n'en finit pas
impuissants les gouvernements de la
quatrième république se heurtent tous à
la question algérienne il faut une
personnalité forte participation
le président de la république de
l'époque rené coty fait alors appel à
charles de gaulle pour former un
gouvernement
ce sera chose faite le 1er juin sept
minutes d'un texte durée du cid
mais de gaulle a aussi les pleins
pouvoirs pour proposer une nouvelle
constitution français la vème république
adoptée par référendum en septembre
cette constitution va tout de suite être
combattue par la gauche et les libéraux
qui craignent le pouvoir personnel de
celui qui allait devenir le premier
président de la cinquième république en
janvier 1959
charles de gaulle aujourd'hui à nouveau
le destin de la france or au delà du
chef politique qui était le général de
gaulle l'écrivain et journaliste michel
tauriac a rassemblé dans un livre les
témoignages des derniers fidèles qui
l'ont côtoyé vivre avec de gaulle c'est
le titre de ce livre c'est aussi le
dossier de cette édition il est signé
jeff vite imbert et pascal stelletta
obstiné impatients séducteur secret
perfectionniste mais aussi attentif aux
autres
derrière le monument d'histoire de
france et un autre de gaulle l'homme qui
se dévoile dans le livre de michel
tauriac on découvre l'humour cinglant du
général le soir d'une réception à
l'elysée
lorsqu'un autre général vient
l'interroger j'aime beaucoup votre les
choses que je ne comprends pas c'est
pourquoi avez vous donné le droit le
droit de vote aux femmes
alors le général et cette réponse c'est
vrai et c'est une question je me suis
longtemps posé peut-être ai-je eu tort
mais je crois qu'il ya un tort pire
c'est que c'est le jour je venais le le
droit de vote aux militaires de baulon
professionnels de la communication bien
avant l'arrivée des communicants et des
publicitaires un futur président de la
république quitte à gauche de l'écran en
faisait son miel j'ai donc assisté à
tout le conseil des ministres de sa
présidence j'ai vu comment ils
s'exprimaient comment il fait passer ses
idées comment il adaptait son action
parce que c'est un homme qu'il adaptait
son acura aux événements et donc j'ai
une espèce de le show le képi poser
détour par la vie intime du général de
gaulle une porte juste entrouverte une
histoire réservés comme ces images
prises pendant la guerre avec yvonne de
gaulle qui deviendra pour les français à
l'elysée
tante yvonne
mais aussi de gaulle qui tombe sous le
charme lors d'une visite officielle des
kennedy
le charme de jackie kennedy et celui des
jolies femmes en général toujours en
voyage à l'erreur alors fait dire à une
femme peut-être belle madame ou alors
madame vous avez 18 ans alors qu'elle en
avait 25 et déjà deux enfants et son
épouse n'étaient pas jalouse son épouse
n'étaient jamais valu ce qu'il disait
toute façon une rolls temps de gaulle a
quitté le pouvoir après le référendum
perdu de 1969 c'est la retraite en
irlande le général et désabusé il était
assez sévère sur les français une
plaisante volontiers sur leur légèreté
contradictions référent c'est un jeune
très simple aucune ou peu de mots qu un
maniérisme
c'était une époque où la vie privée
tenez peu de place dans la vie publique
la santé avec aujourd'hui la 2e journée
européenne contre l'accident vasculaire
cérébral avc en france 150 mille
personnes en sont victimes chaque année
et la moitié de ces personnes gardent
des séquelles irréversibles
on sait que les premières heures juste
après la taxe sont très importantes et
qu'elles nécessitent un traitement
adapté
reportage laurence beauvillard bernie
mériaux services d'urgence
cérébrovasculaires de paris les pompiers
viennent d'amener un homme inconscient
l'irm annonce les dégâts un caillot de
sang bouche un vaisseau une partie du
cerveau n'est plus irrigué
c'est un accident vasculaire cérébral
ici on applique un nouveau traitement on
injecte un produit destiné à dissoudre
ce caillou chaque minute compte
faut faire vite parce que ce traitement
n'est efficace que dans les toutes
premières heures
idéalement dans les 90 minutes sinon
dans les trois heures quelquefois 4 à 5
heures mais après il est trop dangereux
noter l'heure exacte de l'accident
appeler le 15 ou le 18
deux mesures d'urgence essentiel nouvel
agent sylvie thévenet est hospitalisée
depuis une semaine
hématome cérébral elle souffre
d'hémiplégie j'ai une perte d'équilibré
je suis demandé ce qui se passait donc
j'ai appelé le docteur m'a fait donc un
scanner il un on a vu que j'avais fait
un avis et les médecins pensent qu'elle
peut récupérer au prix d'une rééducation
de plusieurs mois et un traitement
médical à vie après un avc non traitées
le risque est neuf fois plus important
de récidive et l'hypertension artérielle
le diabète le tabagisme et le surpoids
sont également des facteurs multipliant
les risques mais la fameuse injection
kyi dissous le caillot de sang n'est
disponible que dans 70 hôpitaux français
maryse thévenet nom n'a pas bénéficié
lors de son avc
c'était il y a deux ans en fait mon
brahim à my sin je n'ai pas récupéré et
donc je continue à faire de la
rééducation à la fois de kini et
d'orthophonie chaque année 150 mille
personnes font un abc une sur cinq ans
meurent et 75000 garde un handicap a dit
un hommage à pascal sevran en l'église
saint louis en l'île ce matin à paris
beaucoup de personnalités politiques et
du monde du spectacle
bertrand delanoë christine albanel et
xavier bertrand mais aussi on l'a aperçu
michel drucker
alain delon rika zaraï
michou ou encore orlando le frère et
producteur de dalida pour qui pascal
sevran avait écrit la chanson il venait
d'avoir 18 ans les obsèques de
l'animateur et parolier devait ensuite
se dérouler dans l'intimité des images
signées jean marie lequertier obsèques
dans l'intimité aussi pour lucien
jeunesse ce matin en l'église saint
melaine à 1 rennes l'animateur de radio
avait animé un carnet rappelons le
pendant 30 ans le célèbre jeu des mille
francs lucien jeunesse avec 89 ans il a
28 ans il est soudain nez et chanteur
emmanuel jal c'est son nom a pourtant un
parcours atypique puisqu'il fut un
enfant soldat
une histoire hors du commun qui fait
l'objet d'un documentaire présenté dans
quelques jours au festival de cannes
en attendant emmanuel jal sort
aujourd'hui un deuxième album au libellé
nous faisons et laurent des bois l'ont
rencontré chez lui à londres les bords
de la tamise
l'image est paisible ordinaire mais lui
gouttes cette banalité
emmanuel jal 28 ans est un ancien enfant
soldat du soudan
il a connu l'enfer comme des milliers
d'autres mais lui a survécu
emmanuel à 6 ans peut-être cette il ne
se souvient pas quand l'armée rebelle
langage de force
aujourd'hui il vit à nombre dans cette
maison il a enregistré son deuxième
album dans lequel il chante sa vie il
combat cinq ans avant d'être sauvé par
une employée humanitaire britannique à
l'âge de 12 ou 13 ans il fui le soudan
et rejoint le ténia quand j'étais enfant
je devais tuer
aujourd'hui encore je me bats je suis
plus âgé mais d'un point de vue
émotionnel j'ai parfois l'impression
d'être un enfant j'ai toujours des rêves
j'ai toujours des poils ainsi qu'aux
logique je suis un enfant soldat
je suis là pour témoigner
je désire investir dans la vie humaine
j'ai l'ambition de créer une école dans
mon pays être utile rendre à ma
communauté le dos quand même rendre lui
à qui l'on a tout volé il y a quelques
mois
emmanuel jal est retourné chez lui au
soudan après quinze années d'exil aux
côtés de son père
au milieu des siens au milieu derrière
lui qui filmé ici enfants adam avait
perdu la force de sourire
une image de football avec l'euphorie la
joie communicative de grenoble hier soir
le club à retrouver la première division
1 grenoble 3e de ligue 2 avec 63 points
assurés hier son billet pour la ligue 1
45 ans après être descendu en ligue 2 en
faisant match nul 0 0 à domicile face à
châteauroux et vous le voyez il y avait
de l'ambiance hier soir avant de
refermer ce journal je vous en rappelle
deux des principaux titres la chine
tente de secourir les victimes du
tremblement de terre dernier bilan 20 à
30000 morts ou disparus sous les
décombres la pluie battante complique
les opérations le régime se dit prête à
accepter l'aide internationale mais pose
ses conditions
et puis encore un gros couac à
l'assemblée pour la loi ogm le texte a
été rejeté faute de mobilisation des
députés ump ont tout à l'heure sur ce
plateau jean françois copé président du
groupe ump à l'assemblée
assumer sa part de responsabilité mais
indiqué que la procédure d'adoption
allait se poursuivre c'est la fin de ce
journal merci de l'avoir suivi tout de
suite la météo tania young
20h50 les vacances de clémence un
téléfilm sur fond de mai 68
à demain
l'info en continu
c'est aussi sur france 2 point fr
le mérite